A ma gauche Julien Marie , dit JUL artiste francais le plus écouté sur les plateformes de streaming musicale
Avec 600 millions d'écoute sur Deezer , Apple , Spotify ,
Le plus regardé sur Youtube avec 600 millions de vues , le plus gros vendeur d'album en France cette année .
A ma droite Nabil et Tarik Andrieu AKA Ademo et N.O.S , les deux frères de PNL
disque d'or et 13 millions d'écoute sur Deezer en moins d'une semaine pour leur dernier album  'dans la légende '
et le million de vues atteint en 14h pour le clip ' Naha' , un record sur Youtube
Deux nouveaux poids lourd du rap francais , mais comment ils sont arrivés là ?
Et pourquoi ils rencontrent un succès pareil ? Et surtout pourquoi ils nous fascinent , autant ?
Que ce soit dans n'importe quel sens ? Juste pourquoi ?
Avant toute chose je vais pas aborder le contenu musical de chaque artiste , chacun est libre d'aimer
, ou pas , ce qu'il veut , l'objectif de se Pop Up ,n'est pas d'analyser leurs musiques , mais de comprendre pourquoi
et comment ils sont déjà devenus cultes.
Et une des premières raisons est l'authenticité , chacun dans leur style ils savent se montrer fidèles à ce qu'ils sont depuis le début.
Prenons JUL pour commencer , il est originaire de Marseille , il met sa ville et sa région à l'honneur dans la plupart de ses clips et de ses textes.
Il fait également participer ses potes depuis toujours dans beaucoup de ses projets.
Pour PNL on retrouve presque le même schéma, originaire de la cité des Tarterets a Corbeille-Essonnes.
Ademo et N.O.S rendent hommage à leur quartier régulièrement , dans le clip ' da ' on les voit même accrocher leur disque d'or dans la MJS des Tarterets.
Et leur entourage est essentiel à leur réussite et à leur vision du monde.
Le fameux '' QLF '' pour ''que pour la famille'' ultra présent dans les textes.
Après pour aimer fortement quelqu'un ou quelque chose, c'est plus facile si on peut s'y identifier.
Et pour s'identifier à un sujet il faut qu'il soit crédible, réel.
On a besoin d'avoir des idoles, pour nous accomplir et nous construire, comme le dit le philosophe Michel Lacroix.
JUL, il est issu d'un milieu populaire, et il s'invente pas une vie, il rappe sont son vrai quotidien, il est fier de son accent Marseillais,
et ne change pas de look, ni d'attitude avec le succès, il se définit lui-même comme un "' rappeur en claquette'''
il dit rouler en Twingo et continuer à boire de l'Oasis.
Pour PNL c'est pareil , les deux frères sont d'anciens dealers et restent fidèles à leurs origines que ce soit dans
les textes ou les clips de leurs chansons, ils racontent leur ancien quotidien avec transparence et sans artifices
et font part de sincérité, de leurs problèmes, ils ne font pas fantasmer leurs fans avec des jacuzzis ou des bimbos qu'ils ne fréquentent pas
Le triptic de clip tout juste achevé lala "Naha" , "Onizouka" et '"Bene" qui racontent une embrouille de dealer de cité est même presque quasi autobiographique
Mais ce n'est pas tout, ce qui les rend authentiques aux yeux du public, c'est aussi leur indépendance
ni l'un ni l'autre , n'a intégré un gros label, les deux ont fondé le leur, JUL avec d'or et platine et PNL avec QLF records,
par contre on n'est pas sur le même style graphique.
De cette manière les artistes sont libérés de toutes contraintes artistiques pouvant être imposés par les majors et gèrent leurs affaires à leurs façons.
PNL et JUL ont créé une vraie mythologie à travers leurs clips et leurs textes, thématique récurrente, référence multiple, look mimique.
Tous ces éléments en les combinant créent un vrai univers dans lequel les fans peuvent se plonger
Et cette mythologie que les deux construisent elle se base aussi sur des références, des références communes à toute une génération ,
et qui nous permet de les rendre plus proches de nous.
Pour PNL c'est Simba, les stars de foot des années 1990 , Mowgli , Dragon Ball, GTO et sa contraste avec leur image de ex dealer,
et ça dévoile leur sensibilité, renforçant encore plus le principe d'authenticité.
JUL lui va parler de sujets beaucoup plus directs, il va pas hésiter à aborder des problématiques directement liées au quotidien des gens,
l'amour ( extrait de JUL ) les galères , les embrouilles avec les potes , le manque d'argent , la cité, ... , voilà
Le mec est vrai et sincère et son audience peut facilement se reconnaitre dans ses textes.
Après il y a la vidéo, depuis l'avènement de MTV dans un premier temps et l'explosion de youtube ces dernières années , le clip est devenu presque aussi important que la chanson.
Et dans ce domaine JUL et PNL ont aussi quelques similitudes , on peut classer leurs clips en deux catégories
entre lesquels ils alternent presque chaque fois.
D'un côté, y a les clips réalisés au quartier, au milieu des leurs pour un petit peu asseoir leur "street creed"
Et de l'autre il y a des concepts vidéos , qui font encore une fois leur singularité,
Pour JUL, par exemple, c'est des quasi courts métrages , parfois drôle , parfois plus sérieux , mais toujours à des années lumières des clichés du rappeur gangsta,
qui boit du Pulpun Drunk et se fait tweerker dessus.
Une cohésion parfaite avec ses textes et sa musique plus festive qui renforce son positionnement . ( geste de main de JUL )
PNL eux ils ont dû pas mal potasser le guide du routard , parce que ils vont dans des décors assez paradisiaque.
aux quatre coins du monde , Namibie , Islande , Japon , Italie , c'est des images qui sont souvent très belles.
Réalisées évidemment par leurs potes , LS , QLF , c'est des images qui sont souvent hypnotisantes,
qui donnent du coup du corps au ''cloud rap" , il y a un côté un peu planant qui se dégage et qui colle bien à la nostalgie de leur musique et leurs lyrics.
Une autre raison de leur succès c'est leur productivité , on a l'impression de les voir tout le temps.
PNL a sorti deux albums en moins de deux ans , le '' mont Chico '' 17 titres et '' dans la légende '' 18 titres c'est déjà beaucoup ,
Mais JUL fait encore plus fort , déjà le type fait tout , production , écriture, c'est un autodidacte , le nombre de sons qu'il a sortis est vertigineux.
Sur l'excellent site '' Genuis '' on peut trouver plus de 200 chansons différentes alors que le mec a tout juste 27 ans.
Et dans une autre interview il revendique avoir écrit 400 autres chansons avant 2012.
D'ailleurs à ses débuts JUL ça donnait ça ( extrait)
Tant qu'on est dans les casseroles , PNL rappait aussi avant d'avoir un style et une dégaine aussi marqué (extrait)
En ne baissant pas leur rythme de production, ils permettent à leurs fans de découvrirent de nouveaux morceaux fréquemment,
Sans qu'ils aient le temps de s'ennuyer ou de se lasser
Ça c'est des similarités, mais là où JUL et PNL sont clairement opposés c'est dans leur rapport aux médias.
Et plus précisément dans l'image qu'ils souhaitent donner d'eux , JUL il joue la carte de la popularité ,
il est un mec normal , qui fait du rap normal et c'est ça qui cartonne.
pas d'artifice , il s'adresse régulièrement et directement à ses fans via ses réseaux sociaux
niveau proximité avec le public il suffit de voir comment il agit sur les réseaux sociaux , il répond à énormément de commentaires, avec plus ou moins de fautes d'orthographe.
Il propose des lives où il explique par exemple comment il va créer un morceau, il fait aussi des passages tv , même s'ils sont rares,
il squate des studios skyrocks , il donne des interviews, il est sans filtre , il propose un rap divertissant , censé faire kiffer les gens sans aucune prétention , en se moquant des critiques .
Et cette force devient  un paradoxe , en agissant de manière ordinaire dans le milieu du rap français ,
il en devient extraordinaire
il casse les codes en vigueur et débarque comme un ovni , d'ailleurs c'est comme sa qu'on l'appelle ( extrait )
PNL fait également figure d'extraterrestre dans le "rap game'" , mais eux ils viennent d'une planète encore différente
à la manière des Daft Punk il ne font aucune apparition publique , aucune interview , ils cultivent le mystère
donne des informations au compte gouttes et n'apparaissent dans aucun média , volontairement
On sait pas grand chose d'eux et ce mystère, il alimente les discussions de fans avec des interprétations , des théories en tout genre.
Il y a seulement le magazin américain assez connu '' the Fader '' qui en a fait une couverture et une interview , et même sur Skyrock ils se sont pas déplacés pour
leur planète rap , laissant le studio a leurs potes QLF .
et à des décors divers rappelant l'univers de leur album,
Et ce côté mystérieux et cette fascination qui entoure PNL elle est accentuée par leurs clips quasi mystiques.
En revanche malgré tout ça ils savent quand même mettre leur communauté à l'honneur.
Cette diversité, ce renouveau, ben c'est une très bonne chose, le rap français il a rarement semblé aussi aussi varié et de qualité
il existe de nombreux artistes très différents qui arrivent à créer des projets et des univers singuliers, tout en touchant une belle audience et de manière indépendante.
ce qui déstabilise parfois les majors.
Qu'on n'aime ou qu'on aime pas c'est un autre débat , mais ce que il faut retenir c'est que JUL et PNL
ils ont des manières d'aborder les choses parce qu'ils sont très proches malgré les apparences.
Mais avec des différences assez fortes, qui les rendent uniques et cette tendance , tendance à l'authenticité
qu'elle soit avec une proximité forte chez JUL ou un mysticisme grand chez PNL , c'est une tendance qui ne touche pas que le rap.
y a qu'à regarder les youtubeurs par exemple.
J'espère que se Pop-Up vous a plu , n'hésitez pas à le partager , mettez moi dans les commentaires ce que vous en avez pensé,
et hésitez pas à lâcher un pouce pour le référencement de la vidéo, ça aide, on se retrouve très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
Love , Peace , ( bisous baveux j'imagine ) ,Ciao.